- Hey guys, welcome to another
episode of "Odd Man Out."
(speaking Spanish)
(speaking Portuguese)
And thank you so much to Skillshare
for sponsoring this episode.
Stick around to the end to learn
how to get a free trial
of premium membership
and check out one of our favorite classes.
Now, let's get to the episode.
How can you tell if someone is a Latino?
Is it by the way they dance
and the music they listen to?
Or is it by the way they look,
or the language they speak?
(speaking Spanish)
- [Paulo] Maybe it's by the food they eat
or their passion for soccer.
- Goal!
(crowd cheers)
- [Paulo] We brought
together seven Latinos.
(all speaking in Spanish)
- [Paulo] One is a liar.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll win a cash prize.
If the liar survives,
they win the cash prize.
This is "Odd Man Out."
(upbeat music)
(lively music)
- Obviously, just from my
face, you're gonna think,
"Is she Latina?"
Like, "Hel...
Like, "Heck no!"
- All I hope is that
I don't get eliminated
in the first round.
'Cause I have so much to
show people about Brazil.
- I'm gonna have to try
to prove my Latino-ness
as soon as I can.
- I'm very nervous, I don't like to lose.
- Hey.
- Hi, guys.
- Hi.
- What's up.
- Hello.
- So where's everyone's from?
- That's the obvious
question. Let's start.
- I'm Puerto Rican/Mexican.
We have a couple of Mexicans here?
- My family's from Los Altos de Jalisco.
- I'm from Dominican Republic.
- I'm from Brazil.
I'm the only one that
speaks Portuguese here.
Damn, I can't prove I speak Portuguese
because no one will understand it.
- I mean, it's similar.
(Tomás speaks Portuguese)
(André speaks Portuguese)
- Yeah, you do.
- Argentina, Buenos Aires.
- Oh, you too as well? Oh wow.
- You guys should ask each
others question to make sure.
(speaks in Spanish)
(Elky laughs)
- What province?
(speaks in Spanish)
- And you, and you?
- What about you, Tomás?
- Me? Well.
I'm living in the U.S.
and I was born in the U.S., but my mom was
from Martinez, Buenos Aires,
and my dad had lived from Avellaneda.
My parents live in Avellaneda.
- You guys' accents are on fire right now.
(participants laugh)
- I'm living in Costa Rica
and I'm actually like super
excited 'cause I feel like
we never get representation like anywhere.
Like everyone knows, like
Argentina, Brazil and whatnot,
but Costa Rica is like, "Puerto Rico?"
I'm like, "No, it's different."
- Yeah, I feel the same thing about like,
representation is super important.
So I'm like half Puerto
Rican, half Mexican
but I was raised by my mom.
So I relate more culturally
with Puerto Rico.
- What about you, Miguel?
- Yeah, Miguel, I wanna hear from Miguel.
- Yeah!
(laughter)
- The only guy that looks lighter than me.
- My parents taught me
both English and Spanish
at the same time, growing up.
People speaking to me in
English just think I'm white
and people speaking to me in Spanish,
just think like I'm Hispanic.
Now Tomás, you mentioned
us looking white though.
Did you ever have like experiences
where people just don't
think you're Latino
because of like how you look?
- Oh yeah, all the time.
People will literally
like, deny it to my face
when I'm literally like, "I am Latino."
Like, "I speak Spanish."
And they'll be like,
"No, you're not. No, you don't."
And I'm like, "How are you gonna tell me--
- And Argentina has a lot
of white people like--
- Yeah.
- André too, 'cause I
was talking to my friend
and she's Brazilian and people are like,
"Brazilians are not Latinos."
But it's like, "Yes,
it's in Latin America,
the biggest country"
- Oh yeah.
- I mean, technically
they're not Hispanic,
but they're definitely Latinos.
- Just talking English,
everyone just assumes
that I'm black and then, no one just says,
no one really ever thinks...
And that's funny, 'cause my girlfriend,
when I came in here then she said,
"Watch you be like the
darkest person here."
And I'm pretty sure
she was right, so.
(participants laugh)
- I went to visit New York
and I was curious to see like
if people would think I was Latina or not
'cause I feel like I don't
give off the vibe sometimes.
Someone told me I was Asian.
- Oh, I can tell you that.
(participants laugh)
- All right.
Oh damn!
(alarm rings)
- For round one, I would
say it was pretty hectic.
- I think they felt I
was legit, hopefully.
- I feel like I didn't speak enough
and I didn't speak in Spanish.
- I'm going to vote, Miguel.
- Miguel.
- Miguel. He doesn't
look at all as a Mexican.
- Miguel is way too obvious.
Elky, you gotta go out
first. You didn't sell me.
- Miguel.
- I am suspicious of Tomás, he showed up
in a Argentina Jersey.
Could just be a fan.
- Angela, she would ask the question,
we would answer and then she
would build off what we said.
So it's kinda easier to, you
know, get an answer from that.
- [Paulo] The votes are in for round one.
- Woo! I'm like, my heart
is racing right now.
- Bro I swear to God--
- And the person eliminated
this round is,
- Don't do it,
don't do it.
- [Paulo] Miguel.
- What? N... Oh my God!
Why would they vote Miguel?
- [All] Bye, Miguel.
- Yeah, I'm really bummed to be out.
I mean, I was looking
forward to sharing my culture
and talking about different
aspects of my culture.
And I just got round one-ded.
(lively music)
- [Paulo] Round two.
This is the Fiesta round.
You'll each have one minute to tell us
about your favorite cultural
or family party tradition.
- I'm very nervous,
but this is gonna be fun.
- I'll have to talk about carnival.
You guys all know, it's the
biggest party in the world.
Basically three million
people in the streets
and we are all dressed in costumes
and we've got our faces painted.
We are all shirtless. Like, the guys only.
The girls, not all of them.
(Elky laughs)
We are high-fiving random
people that we don't know.
We are hugging people.
There's a lot of kissing.
There's also some problems about carnival,
like, you could get robbed but it's okay.
You will still have fun if you get robbed.
Any city you go, there
will be a party going on.
It's crazy. That's the
word to describe it.
- Everything he said, you can just learn
from watching the movie, "Rio,"
the little bird flying around.
- So in Argentina, I
mean, since we're like
a pretty Catholic-dominated
country and all that.
We all celebrate mostly,
Christmas and Navidad.
- He doesn't seem very excited.
- I've been there for
Argentina, and during Argentina,
it's summer in Argentina for Christmas.
So it's different.
There's fireworks going
on, like the whole night.
We eat empanadas. There's
usually asado, obviously.
We take a lot of pride into
it and we like to have fun.
- I feel like there should
be something more exciting,
especially with like football and stuff.
- No matter where you are,
you're more than likely
gonna see fireworks.
- Do you know the different
types of cuts for the meats,
for the asado?
- Like different types
(Aylen laughs)
of meat, yeah right?
- I got him!
- Is this what you're saying?
- Nah, bro.
- There's chinchulin.
There's a lot of stuff.
There's like,
there's more pork, I know.
- That's suspicious.
- I can't give you specifics,
I'm kind of blanking out.
I don't know why.
- I mean, he didn't
know how to answer that,
so I don't know how to feel about that
'cause I mean, there's a lot of cuts.
- Tomás is sus.
- The fiesta that my
family loves to celebrate
is New Year's.
Well, a staple is asado,
like how I told you,
there's like, matambre, entraña,
chinchulin, chorizo.
- Okay there you go, yeah.
- But that's like the generic, right?
- She is definitely Latina, all the way.
- For music, like we're
known for el tango,
but really, what's
playing in the background
is gonna be cumbia like,
(Aylen sings a tune)
like all your cousins
are gonna be like that.
(Tomás sings a tune)
And everybody is gonna
have like, the Messi jersey
and it's gonna always be playing soccer
or football in their background.
- Latinos love soccer.
- Everybody's gonna be like,
"Ole, ole, ole, ole!"
- It's crazy.
- That's like the whole house.
- Yeah you go crazy.
- Or "Dale campeon!"
- [Aylen And Tomás] "Dale campeon!"
(Elky laughs)
- Messi!
We're gonna be making chocotorta, flan,
gelatina, brownie,
- Oh she knows what
she's talking about
- colillallo.
- She's way more well-spoken than I am.
she's way more prepared
than me, of course.
- Yo, if she's the impostor, bro I quit.
- So, the thing about Dominicans is like,
they will find an excuse
to party any time, any day,
it doesn't even matter.
(Aylen squeals)
So it's funny, cause like.
- I know!
- In DR, even though,
July 4th and Thanksgiving
is a holiday, only in America,
if they hear about it they're like, "Ah,
that's a good day to party."
(Elky laughs)
So we'll party that day too.
- Hey, that's true.
- We celebrate Christmas, December 24th.
And then we party all night long
- Latinos never celebrate
on the 25th, that's facts.
- We would spend the whole night,
I'm talking about like,
till 4:00 in the morning,
listening to music,
dancing, bachata, merengue,
salsa, tipico, all that stuff.
- I love bachata so much.
- And then we all wake up into
like 1:00 pm the next day.
- Okay, so my favorite tradition
is around Christmas time
we all know, we love Christmas, right?
So we make tamales.
My grandma lives in a place called Venezia
and she has like a big
quinta or like, finca.
- Wait that's so cool.
I'm like so happy, someone said quinta.
- You normally get with your family
and you make like a long table
and each person has a responsibility.
So one person puts like the masa on
and the other person
puts like the pork or...
- That's cute.
- some people like
to put carrots and bell pepper or chila.
I really enjoy it because it's, you know
when you get to be with your family
and you're all kind of like
doing something all together,
you have your music, you have your laughs,
and then you have
someone like scolding you
because you're doing it wrong.
- Okay, the scolding part, true!
- So my favorite family tradition
party is Three Kings' Day.
And it's very, very
popular in Puerto Rico.
It's about two weeks after Christmas.
You and your whole family,
you go to their house
you're Christmas caroling,
but Latino style, right?
- So you have music,
(Elky laughs)
instruments, dancing, singing.
And then you have a big party.
You have food, you have
arroz con gandules,
you have all types of meat, drinks.
We have coquito there, and
you just stay up all night.
Sometimes you just have coffee
- She's actually
- And everything.
- pretty educated on this.
- And so that's kind of one of my,
most favorite family traditions
turned party style.
(bell rings)
- I hope I did a good job
representing my country.
- Aylen asked a really good question,
which, any Argentinean would know
and I'm stupid for messing
up because, I don't know,
I just drew a blank. I
couldn't think of it.
- Angela talked last and
shared less details about her story.
- I'm gonna vote Tomás, because I think
other people might vote him.
- André, I would have liked to see more
about his family traditions.
- Tomás.
- I'mma just say André.
Where's the passion, bro?
- Oh, I don't know man, I'mma say Elky.
- [Paulo] We counted all
the votes for round two.
And we have a tie
between André and Tomás.
- Oh no.
- Ooh!
- I knew I would be chosen.
- These people are crazy. (chuckles)
- [Paulo] We will go into a tiebreaker
where each of you will have
20 seconds to state your case.
Tomás, you're up for first.
- I understand why you
might have chosen me.
And I did mess up on
something pretty stupid
which was the meat cuts
(Elky laughs)
and all that of asado
and damn yeah, obviously.
- Ooh, he already know
what he about to get
voted off for. (laughs)
- Oh no, I feel so bad!
- But, Aylen knows for a fact,
that there's some things that,
somebody that's not from
Argentina, wouldn't have said
And I don't know, I
feel like we could have,
as soon as her and I started
speaking, we like connected.
You guys could tell.
(alarm rings)
(Aylen laughs)
(speaking in Portuguese)
- Okay, the accent.
(Aylen squeal)
- That's it!
(continues speaking in Portuguese)
- Man, I didn't wanna do that.
- Okay, okay, okay, I'm like...
(continues speaking in Portuguese)
- That's basically what I said,
I hope you guys understood.
(alarm rings)
- Just because you speak Portuguese,
doesn't make you Brazilian.
- I'm gonna still vote Tomás.
- André.
- I'm voting André. Tomás
don't let me down, man.
- I'm quite upset that
I'm in this predicament
'cause they already know
that they're gonna choose me.
- [Paulo] We have counted all the votes,
and the person eliminated
this round is...
(Elky laughs)
- (sighs) Oh my God, my heart.
- André.
- Oh.
- Yes!
- There we go.
Oh, I'm sorry.
(Tomás huffs)
- I don't know why. (chuckles)
I think they connected
better, in terms of culture.
- That is crazy. For the
first time in my life,
I've been accepted into
the Latino community.
(soft music)
- So I feel like the
biggest misconception,
that I get is the language and the accent.
I lived in United States
illegally for a while,
so I lost a little bit of Spanish
and I feel like, I met a lot of Latinos
who didn't speak Spanish.
So a lot of people are like,
"Oh if you don't speak Spanish,
you're not Latino, right?"
I'm like, "No."
And then, since I do speak fluent English,
guys like, expect me to
have a sexy Latina accent.
And I'm like, "No, I speak fluent English.
That doesn't make me less of a Latina."
- Just from looking at my face,
yeah, I am Korean. I'm Asian.
My grandparents, my
parents are all from Korea
but they all lived in
Argentina for 30 years
and, I was born there.
I lived there for 15 years.
Even there, people used
to always call me like,
(speaks in foreign language)
which means like, "Oh,
like, you're an Asian chic."
Like, "You don't belong here."
And even here in the U.S.
when I do speak Spanish,
they're like, "Why are
you speaking Spanish?"
Like, "Who let you speak Spanish?"
And I'm like, "Excuse me," like.
And so I think that's a
really big misconception
that just because you look Asian,
because you might not look
like the standard person
who comes from Latin America,
that you can't be Latina, Latino, Latinx,
and that you always have to speak Spanish.
But you really don't.
I think it's the culture
that matters, the music,
what you share with others, so yeah.
- First of all, the misconception
about like all Dominicans,
is the fact that none of them
want to take and acknowledge
that they have any African descent.
- Okay, that's so true.
- Like you mention
to any Dominican that like,
"Oh you have black in you, right?"
They're like, "No, no.
I'm not black. I'm not black."
- So true.
- Your skin tone, your hair, everything,
you have African descent in
you, you have to acknowledge it.
- Colorism and racism in the
Latina community is huge.
It's a problem.
I didn't grow up speaking Spanish.
And it wasn't until middle school,
that I took Spanish classes.
And so I always passively knew it,
but never actively got
the chance to learn it.
Sometimes you feel like, "Oh,
I might not be Latinx enough
or Latina enough, because I
don't speak fluent Spanish."
The main thing I wanna talk about really,
is just like emphasizing that
there's not one cookie cutter
of what it means to be Latina
as long as you share that value
down the communities.
- Yes, yes. Thank you Angela.
- All of that is really important.
- Okay, I have something
super funny to ask.
Vacunas. Do you guys have...
- That's another thing,
oh my God!
- Yes, birthmark.
- Damn!
- Vacuna!
- I am so jealous, I tell my mom that,
that's so crazy you said that.
I tell every Dominican this,
"I am so jealous of every Dominican
that has that little mark there."
Because I'm like, bro,
like I can't even be like,
"Look, look, I have it."
I'm like...
(Elky laughs)
- I mean, I don't have it,
I was born in the U.S.,
and like, I didn't get that.
- The thing is, as long as you
know what I'm talking about,
I know you're Latino.
- Yeah, I know
what you're talking about.
- Oh my goodness, I was like,
we don't have the vacunas,
"You're not Latino." But obviously,
I understand there's like
- Yeah, that's the same thing
they say to me, man.
- Certain situations.
You just made me worse.
- No, that means
you're Latino, it's okay.
It's like the small little
things that make a big impact.
(bell rings)
- Exactly.
- Elky, I feel so bad
'cause I voted for Elky
the whole time,
but like, Elky brought up the la vacuna
and she knew it and she has it.
- I probably gonna vote for Angela,
just because she says
the most generic things.
- I think I'm gonna vote Tomás,
just because I think
everyone else is going to
and it's better to be safe than sorry.
- Again, Tomás.
- Tomás, and I'm so sorry.
- I'm sorry Tomás.
I saved you last time,
I can't save you again.
- [Paulo] The person
eliminated this round,
is...
- Bro, they better
not do me.
- [Paulo] Tomás!
(David sighs)
- I'm so sorry.
- I did it to him,
he's out.
- I feel betrayed.
Stabbed in the back.
- This is basically my family right now.
I'm getting rid of him. I'm sorry.
- [Paulo] Do you wanna continue the game?
Give me thumbs up, if you
wanna go to round four.
Give me a thumbs down, if
you think you caught them all
and want to end the game now.
- (beep) I don't know what to do.
(timer ticking)
(gong dinging)
(Elky laughs)
- [Paulo] Majority has voted
and we will end the game now.
(upbeat music)
- Can I say something real quick?
Listen, if any of you
guys are still the moles,
we gon' have some problems.
I swear on everything.
(Aylen laughs)
- [Paulo] If the color
turns green, you all win.
If it's red, the mole is still
in the game and you lost.
In three,
two,
one.
- Let's go!
(participants cheer)
Mom, I won.
(Elky laughs)
- Mom!
- Now I'm gonna go apologize
to Tomás. (giggles)
- I'm sorry Tomás.
- I'm so happy.
- Oh, wait. Oh my God.
- I was like, "I'm so sorry."
(lively music)
- [Paulo] The game is over
and the Latinos have won.
That means that the winners
will be receiving a cash prize.
And we're also going to be gifting them
the Akinto experience,
where you'll get to pick
your favorite basics
from our new interactive apparel brand.
Will the mole please raise your hand,
in three,
two,
one.
(participants exclaim)
- Come on now.
- We got him, in the first!
- I knew it.
- It was so painful
- Literally the first round.
- to keep on voting.
- Yeah.
- My name in the game is Miguel Rosa.
My actual name is Michael Rose.
- Ah!
- I am not a Latino,
as you guys guessed.
I studied abroad for a semester
and I loved it. A bunch
of guys were all Mexican.
- André, I'm so sorry bro.
- Oh, don't worry.
- Me too! I'm sorry.
- No one can speak that perfect.
- And that's why I thought I messed up
because I had to prove myself.
And I didn't even speak
Spanish and I was like,
and this guy just starts spitting,
the best Portuguese ever.
(participants laugh)
- I'm happy for them.
I hope there wasn't too much turmoil.
And like, after that when they were like
picking apart other Latinos.
- Even though Miguel is not a Latin,
he has a Latin spirit.
Latin is here, like in our
minds and in your heart
- It's about family, friends, fun, food.
- Latinos are everywhere and
they can look like anything.
- If you don't speak
Spanish, it doesn't matter.
If you haven't tried
this traditional food,
it doesn't matter, that doesn't make you
any less of a Latino. That just means
we're gonna have to show
you new things. That's all.
- As long as you know that you're Latino,
that's all that matters.
- But yeah. See you guys. (lips smack)
- I hope you enjoyed that
episode of "Odd Man Out".
And thanks so much to Skillshare
for sponsoring this video.
As someone who was born
and raised in Brazil,
I could really relate to a lot of things
that the cast members said.
And I just really love the part when André
just started speaking Portuguese
because I could actually
understand everything he said.
It just made me miss
my home country so much
and want to visit again soon.
And on Skillshare, there's
actually a photography class
that I've been taking from
a Brazilian photographer
who lives in Rio de Janeiro.
The class is called,
"Photography Basics: Becoming
a Professional Instagrammer"
by Paolo Del Valle.
And in this class, he
covers a lot of things like
camera selection, how to take
engaging Instagram photos,
how to edit your photos,
and my favorite part,
building a strategy to get
you noticed on Instagram,
especially by brands.
I highly recommend taking that
class or one of the thousands
other classes that Skillshare
has to offer on topics
like animation, writing, film,
and other creative things.
There's no ads on Skillshare
so there's no interruption
while you're learning.
And they're always coming
out with premium classes
that you can get for less than $10 a month
with an annual subscription.
And for the first 1000
subscribers to click
on the link in the description,
you'll get a free trial of
Skillshare premium membership.
So yeah, go to Skillshare,
learn new things, have fun,
and don't forget to like this video
and share it with your friends.
(speaks in foreign language)
(upbeat music)